اما حرب اليمن
التي تسببت لنا بكل هذه الازمة
فلن تستمر الى الابد
الحروب لا تستمر الى الابد
وسياتي يوم يجلس فيه المتحاربون
على الطاولة ويتصافون ويوقعون
سلام الشجعان عند اذن ارجو ..ارجو
ان تتذكروا  انه ذات يوماً  قام رجل من لبنان
ودعا لوقف تلك الحرب
محبة با اليمن
هل وصلت السعودية غايتها
باستقالة جورج قرداحي؟
وكيف استطاعت السعودية
إبعاد قرداحي عن الحكومة؟
وهل من العدل أن تقطع الدعم والمعونات
عن شعب بأكمله لأن شخصا قال كلاما يعارضك؟
ما الذي عملته السعودية في لبنان؟
وما هي الضغوطات والتهديدات التي تلقاها قرداحي
ليقدم استقالته؟
وما هي الأوضاع في لبنان اليوم؟
وهل لأوضاع لبنان علاقة باليمن
فلذلك أصدر القرداحي تصريحاته عن اليمن؟
ثم ألم يقل القرداحي كلمة الحق التي يقولها
أعضاء في الكونغرس الأمريكي،
ويقولها العالم أجمع،
بل خرج المسؤولون في السلطة اليمنية المدعومة من السعودية
لينتقدوها وينتقدوا حربها العبثية في اليمن،
فما هو الفرق بين كل هذه التصريحات
وتصريح القرداحي؟
....
بعد ضغوطات وتهديدات رهيبة على جورج قرداحي
وعلى الحكومة اللبنانية والدولة بأكملها
من دول الخليج وعلى رأسها السعودية
استقال القرداحي فهل يكتفي الخليجيون بهذا؟
كل ما في الأمر أن القرداحي خرج ليقول
أن الحرب في اليمن العبثية،
هل قال القرداحي شيئا آخر؟
لا لم يقل .. هل قلل القرداحي من احترامه للسعودية والخليج؟
لا لم يفعل
بل خرج وقال كل الحب والاحترام للسعودية
ولدول الخليج جميعها لكن كان هناك كلمة حق
يجب أن تقال فقيلت،،،
فما الضير في هذا؟
استدعت السعودية بعد ذلك سفيرها في لبنان
وطردت السفير اللبناني وأجبرت عددا من الدول الخليجية
بالسير على نهجها في هذا الجانب،
حتى أنها جعلت اليمن تمشي على ذات النهج،،،،
..
القرداحي لم يعلن الحرب على السعودية
لكن السعودية أعلنت حربها بجميع الطرق والوسائل
على لبنان والقرداحي، ولو أن باستطاعتها غزو لبنان
لفعلت، لماذا كل هذا يا آل سعود؟
..
بعد أن قطعت السعودية المعونات والغذاء والدعم المادي
عن لبنان الذي صار ثلثا شعبه يعيشون تحت خط الفقر
بعد أن كانوا من الطبقة المتوسطة،
ما كل هذا العبث السعودي في لبنان؟
...
(استقالة قرداحي)
صمد جورج قرداحي وأعلن أنه لا يتحدى أحد
لكن يرفض الاستقالة،
فهو ليس موظفا في شركة ليستقيل وتنتهي المشكلة،
وإنما هو وزير في دولة ذات سيادة
يقف من وراءه حزب وحكومة تبحث عن الاستقرار،،،
بعد رفض قرداحي للاستقالة ماذا عملت السعودية؟
مارست السعودية جميع الضغوطات على الحكومة اللبنانية،
وليس هذا فحسب بل ألقت بهذه الضغوطات على قرداحي نفسه؟
فأمرت بتسريح جميع أقرباء القرداحي من وظائفهم،
وضغطت على الحكومة اللبنانية أن لا تجتمع
حتى يستقيل قرداحي، وماذا بعد؟
ضخت السعودية أموالها شرقا وغربا لتكسب الدعم الدولي،،،
وهنا أخيرا كسبت دعم الرئيس الفرنسي إيمانويل ماكرون،
الذي قرر زيارتها، لكن جعلوه يضغط على الحكومة اللبنانية
ليستقيل قرداحي وهو ما كان،،،
وهنا ...
أعلن وزير الإعلام اللبناني جورج قرداحي،
في ال ٣ من ديسمبر لعامنا الحالي ٢٠٢١،
أنه قدم استقالته لرئيس الجمهورية ميشال عون
ورئيس الحكومة نجيب ميقاتي...
وقال القرداحي:
أتقدم إليكم بطلب استقالتي من منصبي كوزير للإعلام
تقديما للصالح العام وأتمنى منكم قبول الطلب".
وكان القرداحي قد قال سابقا : "منذ اليوم الأول
قلت إن كانت استقالتي تفيد فأنا جاهز لها...
لقد حان وقت الاستقالة وانا مقتنع بأنني اخترت القرار الصحيح
في التوقيت الصحيح، ولذلك أشعر براحة داخلية.
وأضاف: لا اريد ان أعطي مجالاً لأحد كي يتهمني لاحقاً
بأنني أضعتُ على لبنان فرصة زيارة الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون للسعودية والتي يمكن أن تكون محطة مناسبة
لبدء معالجة الازمة مع السعودية،
ولا أريد أن افسح المجال أمام تحميلي مسؤولية أي إجراء سلبي
قد يُنفذ ضد المغتربين في الخليج،
وسيكتشف اللبنانيون انني لست سبب ما يعانونه هم،
وما تعانيه الحكومة من مشكلات أراد البعض تحميلي إيّاها
زوراً وبهتانا..
وفي مؤتمره الصحفي عقب الاستقالة..
قال
بالنسبة لليمن وحرب اليمن
ستنتهي الحرب وسيجلس المتحاربون يوما على الطاولة
كا الشجعان للسلام، فالحرب لن تستمر طويلا،
وأرجو أن يتذكر اليمنيون أن رجلا لبنانيا
قام ودعا إلى وقف تلك الحرب محبة باليمن
ومحبة بالسعودية ومحبة بالإمارات ومحبة بكل الخليج...
لا تحزن يا صديقي تقولها لسان حال كل اليمنيين لقرداحي،
فسيأتي يوم يثبت كل ما قلته فالحرب في اليمن ليست سوى حرب عبثية،
وحصار لبنان بسبب تصريحك بالحق،
ليس سوى حقد دفين على كل من يعارض حكام الخليج،،
عندها سيعود إليك حقك وستعود لليمن
ولبنان عافيتهما...
فهل يكون هذا اليوم في القريب العاجل؟